m
non
oh
perdu dans l'hiver olala est là alors il
ya certainement ma fille et mon fils qui
regarde l'émission c'est pas la vérité
voilà ça s'est aggravé jeu car je tiens
à rassurer les aurions bien sûr a
simplement pourquoi parce que d'une part
pour vous faire plaisir et d'autres pas
se faire un cadeau de la production
aujourd'hui puisque c'était mon
anniversaire de son anniversaire
ne vous inquiétez pas il j'ai tout prévu
pour toutes à leurs yeux et je vous
ferez votre anniversaire pendant le
prime de toulalan j'ai très peur
non là je vous aurais c'est du gros
caillou bon vous inquiétez pas c'est du
bon c'est un beau cadeau
oui j'imagine bien en tout cas il ya une
bonne ambiance mais on va arrêter de
rire une minute si terrible ma baguette
est en berne
non l'heure est grave ça semble être de
votre copine aujourd'hui n'est plus un
triste jour sur le pape vous l'avait
annoncé cyril motus va s'arrêter pendant
quelques temps je vous propose de rendre
hommage à ceux qui nous ont quittés
merci de ne pas applaudir ce soir on
pense très fort à la boule numéro
32 38 à la boule numéro 22 a la boule 19
à la boule 3 et surtout à saluer
l'artiste maudit bon gars ben j'espère
j'espère bien je peux pas croire je suis
pas bien mais en tout cas vous êtes tous
très mignon là par les télés depuis des
années mais vous êtes à la ramasse les
petits pois
parce que l'avenir c'est internet mais
oui c'est le tueur fou comme dit gérard
louvin il ya un petit côté booba ont
fait un point geeks et les dykes du jour
ce sont les élèves de l'école siec qui
sont très très moderne puisqu'elle fonde
et celle filles avec leur tablette qui
n'en est pas une impasse que si on zoome
on s'aperçoit qu'il s'agit d'un mac
on voit bien le port usb le firewire et
claude hardy j'aimerais effectivement
balle alors attention cyril way tours de
magie vous me confirmer que nous sommes
bien à boulogne
oui et bien pas bien pas font part aux
états unis pour suivre le dossier
bizarre non mais parce que la baguette
s'est cassé la glace avait répété ça
marche encore la tempête de neige qui
balaie les états unis quelques écoles
ont dû fermer certains directeurs au
prévenu les parents et les élèves avec
un simple mail classique et d'autres ont
opté pour une version beaucoup plus
original c'est le cas du principal match
glendinning qui pour annoncer la
fermeture de son école à parodier notre
chanson préférée celle de la reine des
neiges je m'en lasse pas
quoi
c'est ça
m
on espère
1 ça fait plaisir de voir jean pierre
coffe en plus dans ce cas oui il va bien
s'est il va très bien millions 3,2 vu
300 milles pour être précis merci merci
voilà je tiens les comptes allait le
petit coquinou du jour qui cache bien
car aujourd'hui est bizarre c'est que
vous faites et 26 noms là les jeunes et
fougueux la foule bus la fugace le petit
coquinou du jour qui cache bien son jeu
c'est le député ump bernard acoyer il
intervenait à l'assemblée à propos de la
loi macron il nous a offert le lapsus du
jour qui a fait rire tout l'hémicycle
car oui on peut être député et mais se
fendre la margoulette je cite votre
préféré or ce dont le pays aurait besoin
c'est justement d'une loi du cheix d'une
voix du siècle en mission sur le
ministre carr ossements l'apport au
diable et on reste dans notre thématique
petits coquinous est ce que dans le 13h
de jpp on est tombé sur un ami intime de
jean michel
alors c'est très bête mais ça nous a
beaucoup fait rire
il a neigé sur les hauteurs des forêts
de longemer après 2000 mètres d'altitude
mais pas de quoi arrêter jacques unis
qui rend visite à gisèle bonjour
monsieur qu'est né un jour monsieur
cluny je viens de voir usa
monsieur qu'une
et je suis né juste à côté c'est dans
les vosges dans les vosges mais à
quelques kilomètres il est tout de suite
oui en plus chaud plus le poisson
oui j'en avais partie de suite allé
préparer une prime non mais ça n'en vaut
pas ce qu'ils doivent préparer vraiment
doit se préparer
allez vous détailler un peu que l'on
connaît ils sont au bout du rouleau
parce qu'il a une odeur de poisson les
gallas et les vitrines on n'était pas
bien mais c'est pas facile à léon copin
parents ils se les caille
non merci on ferme une lame écoles cette
attention qui m'a beaucoup touché cyril
puisque aujourd'hui 28 janvier vous avez
tenu à appeler quelqu'un dans votre
émission de radio pour lui souhaiter un
bon anniversaire dans un premier temps
j'étais tout toucher hyper content j'ai
couru regarder le rituel sourire aux
lèvres et mon monde s'est effondré parce
que c'est pas moi vous voulez appeler
mes cibles c'est lé nom et basse
vous avez voulu appeler nicolas sarkozy
car môssieur ne gravitent que dans les
hautes sphères belle performance en tout
cas attention première étape le standard
immo jours suivants siège de l'ump
bonjour c'est cyril hanouna ça va bien
ça va vous apprendre
on est à la radio n'est sûr on voulait
se tait bonne anniversaire à nicolas
sarkozy on est bien reçu
oui bonjour je suis au secrétariat
nicolas sarkozy oui bonjour bonjour
c'est cyril hanouna ça va bien oui ça va
je vous appelle de la radio fait on
descend on voulait souhaiter bon
anniversaire à nicolas ben parce que
c'est l'anniversaire
il est en train de réfléchir si procès
sur sûrement repensé
ces villes c'est bien c'est lent parce
que là on a bipé la radio c'est avec
personne ne sait que ces essais qui ont
comparé tous derrière ils ont inversé au
bâti on retournait dans mille îles sur
quoi nous lie est sûre pour europe 1 je
sais pas c'est quoi ça avec dechavanne
vous ouais c'est vrai examen c'est vrai
alors va-t-il répondent nicolas sarkozy
le suspense est insoutenable perso moi
je vous aurais répondu direct sans
assistance mais vous avez appelé sarko
grave étape 2 alors oui merci merci vous
êtes un amour allo président oui bonjour
c'est cyril hanouna on est sûr dans les
pieds dans le plat vous voulez vous
souhaiter bon anniversaire
quelque chose de sûre de tenir que j'ai
ce pas son temps et 60
allez-y
c'est vraiment j'étais très très étonné
qu'ils me répondent non mais franchement
j'ai pas la route a fait ça tu dis on va
tomber sur le standard et puis moi au
téléphone et il dit est apparemment le
vans beaucoup puisqu'il dit c'est bien
la première fois que vous allez
m'appeler sans arrière-pensée après il
ya eu jean pierre foucault il fait à lui
je sais que c'est sincère c'est ben
voilà donc pour qu'il n'y ait pas parce
que je sais que au ps et paraît que ça
grince des dons 1 donc demain
j'appellerai le président voilà françois
hollande donc même si c'est pas son
anniversaire je l'appellerai demain tu
yves lesage voilà qu'apple est ce que je
peux lui dire à françois hollande c'est
que nicolas sarkozy m'a répondu donc
voilà c'est on peut lire je ne
l'appellerai et moi ce serait 100
pigeons
voilà est devenu très remplie refermer
la victoire est bien avec ma sortie plus
tôt cette année
c'était un gars il
voix savez tout
oh